et est-ce que tu as des news est-ce que
ça avance ça avance doucement
ce weekend normalement vous auriez bien
voir il y a eu des SMS
[Musique]
ici
[Rires]
c'est très bien
[Musique]
merci
si ça sec il y a quand même tout un
chemin d'éveiller
un peu le chasse-neige par exemple
pour déblay alors je te dis la vérité je
te dise perso
sur lui arrête de te voir
elle se sent pas prête physiquement mais
faut m'appeler je te le faire tu as dit
walpes
il faudrait que je m'habitue avec
quelqu'un que je connais déjà bien
[Applaudissements]
j'ai déjà raconté j'ai déjà raconté moi
moi j'ai j'ai voulu me raser comme ça
complètement mais pas avec les trucs
bien tu vois il y aura comme ça tu vois
alors au début tu vois tu as une petite
barbe de trois jours au bout de tu vois
c'est beau gosse tu vois ça fait un peu
tu vois ça fait un peu ghostbo tu vois
c'est sympa
le problème
le problème c'est qu'au bout d'un mois
franchement
au bout d'un mois tu as lui dans le slip
non mais vraiment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il est là il est là toi
tu restes là d'accord mais il est là
pourquoi pourquoi vous avez rasé votre
petit duvet qui est devenu poil
exactement elle était esthéticienne
qu'on lui présente
en même temps il
[Rires]
il faut voir mais il faut que je vois
encore avec l'assistante maternelle car
j'ai déjà non mais je l'ai déjà prise la
semaine dernière un peu tard donc ça va
être compliqué d'accord alors à ton avis
quand est-ce que je te bouffe la chnek
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pourquoi tu as pas regardé avec lui face
à Baba non mais c'est vrai
dans le public
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je peux pas l'appeler là
[Rires]
je vois pas
elle appelle le vin mais le haut-parleur
c'est sexy les lunettes
juste pour voir
sinon elle va appeler sa mère donc ce
que tu veux venir voir face à Baba
demain et après on va faire un snack
parti alors
regardez l'émission Stéphane
[Applaudissements]
le numéro des pompiers ce serait pour
une
[Rires]
mais je peux pas dire
est-ce que est-ce que ça vous dirait un
petit un nouveau petit date demain
est-ce que vous êtes disponible ou pas
la boîte à secret je sais c'est vraiment
tu as plus rien à faire de voilà c'est
vraiment c'est le dernier truc avant la
mort
il y a la boîte à secret puis après
normalement tu décides
Stéphane
c'est pas grave tu veux dire la vérité
ça me fait énormément de peine de dire
ça mais alors tu privilégies dans la
boîte à Secret
ah bah la boîte à bonheur
[Rires]
est-ce que tu veux l'amener avec toi ah
voilà moi
[Applaudissements]
Stéphane tu peux te dire vraiment ce que
je ressens
je sens que tu cours plusieurs Schneck à
la fois
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est vrai je te dis la vérité
[Musique]
tu vas déjà avec quelqu'un voilà
[Applaudissements]
tu dors il a raison Stéphane tu es sur
quel bail toi
[Rires]
[Musique]
je préfère la vérité
tu vas
Stéphanie
[Applaudissements]
voilà et je te comprends parce qu'à un
moment je vais te dire tu sais Daniel un
moment Daniel un moment quand tu as ton
bus le bus il passe si tu montes pas
dedans tu resteras toujours au même
endroit
toi tu es toute la journée à l'arrêt de
bus tu le prends jamais non mais c'est
vrai à un moment Stéphane il a envie
voilà lui lui bah ça y est il est parti
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
contrairement c'est un discours
d'escrocs
gentleman Stéphane il veut laisser il
veut prendre le temps il faut prendre le
temps il est chaud voilà il est sur
voilà il est sur des il a des amis
Daniel en fait partie voilà c'est Daniel
alors voilà
j'ai l'impression qu'il peut pas te
déranger
[Applaudissements]
tu nous raconteras la boîte à Secret mon
chéri on te fait un gros bisou on se
rappelle demain
bah bien sûr
j'adore j'adore la boîte à Secret moi
j'adore les invités c'est qui
pas mal j'adore ouais
t'es pas sur Jenifer dois-je
[Rires]
Jennifer et inversement c'est énorme
exactement les mêmes les mêmes bases
elles sont les mêmes ex non mais c'est
vrai voilà je tombe très fort mon chéri
salut mon chef on t'aime et on t'aime et
reviens nous voir
ah bon
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
Daniel comment tu le sentes il a la
vérité moi je pense que je viens de me
prendre le deuxième râteau après genre
je fais naître en direct
alors attends je devais faire quoi là on
est devant chez moi il est minuit
qu'est-ce que je devais faire
ce soir
c'était mercredi tu le relance pour voir
le voir le weekend
il faut vraiment que tu fasses plus
d'efforts
tu veux que je te dise la vérité je veux
dire un truc
en fait moi j'aurais kiffé je trouve que
Daniel a et en fait Daniel c'est pas une
info ouais Daniel c'est une meuf
vraiment bien et Daniel elle relance pas
derrière moi tu vois moi j'aurais kiffé
Daniel voilà je trouve que la bonne
attitude malheureusement
on a le tour
isme
[Rires]
bon voilà moi je te dis là je vais vous
dire la vérité ça me fait pas plaisir je
trouve que ce côté là niveau amour il
est horrible
Géraldine
depuis 1977
[Rires]
j'ai rien dit je fais une nouvelle
coiffure vous me détruisez merci de
bagues non mais je suis arrivé
est-ce que la solution ce serait pas de
recoller les morceaux par exemple nous
deux c'est ça ton problème
elle est dans le public de la boîte à
sucre
très beau non mais c'est cohérent je
veux dire non mais ça veut dire qu'il
est sur un bail voilà après on va voir
peut-être que demain la meuf dans le
public elle va péter il va être des
toutes les options sont
possibles c'est toi ta chance toi est-ce
que tu le désires ce monsieur non mais
elle elle désire personne
d'autre fois où j'ai pas accepté il est
pas mal là d'entendre sa voix est-ce que
tu as vécu des choses des papillons dans
ton ventre
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie de te voir ce soir voilà
viens on se voit et on est là toutes les
lois de la terre
il ne pensera plus qu'à toi demain toute
la journée avec même avec l'autre
tout de suite
exactement
[Applaudissements]
nationale vas-y fais un signe faites un
signe n'importe lequel merci
[Applaudissements]
vous avez un choix cornélien pour demain
j'ai envie de te voir ce soir
ou la boîte
la boîte à joujou
pour Daniel
je vois bien que tu veux parler depuis
tout à l'heure
mais pourquoi tu lui envoies un petit
nude une photo
tu as dépassé les bornes
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie de vous voir ce soir
voyons-nous à 22h30
elle va dormir
[Applaudissements]
dans deux minutes c'est moi qui vais le
sucer
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
une photo de ton tarpé
arrêtez tout mais c'est la gérer
cette émission est en train de prendre
une tournure
regardez les yacht il croit que le micro
il croit que le micro
est-ce que par exemple plutôt que le
théâtre dans quelques jours est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas frapper les trois coups ce
soir directement
je crois qu'on l'envoie dans le mur
est-ce qu'on frapper les trois coups ce
soir directement
après les trois coups
ce soir vous êtes vous êtes en monter
on s'appelle on s'appelle ce soir
on s'appelle
on a une chance de se voir et on a une
chance de on a une chance de se voir
alors à tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure
à tout à l'heure
on a une amie
on a une émission à faire à tout à
l'heure
s'il vous plaît alors je vais avoir
l'analyse de Valérie Benaim et Kelly et
Dominique d'ailleurs dans le dans des
débutants
quand elle parle elle lui parle par la
négative on ne pourrait pas se voir ce
soir évidemment qui va dire bah non je
peux pas alors que si elle dit
voyons-nous ce soir c'est affirmatif et
il va dire
par la négative
alors moi je crois que c'est un gros
escroc
[Applaudissements]
c'est un escroc il cherche la lumière
sur les plateaux
télévenu
là c'est pas bon là là là vraiment c'est
n'importe quoi ils sont chargés je le
respecte
moi je l'adore il a le droit il a vu
Daniel voilà ils sont en train de jouer
avec les hommes qui ne sont pas honnêtes
il est pas honnêtes avec elle il veut
pas la voir
moi j'adore Daniel mais pour moi
l'escroc c'est pas lui c'est toi
quand même maintenant que tu te mouilles
un peu voilà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une belle rencontre c'est un type
absolument charmant vous avez plein de
points communs il adore le tag comme toi
voilà rappelle-moi il faut que tu sois
un tout petit peu plus à l'initiative
des choses à faire des choses soient
elles vont pas tomber comme ça du ciel
elle lui a quand même proposé de le voir
ce soir il a recalé
tu fais trop de darka un moment il faut
y aller cash j'ai arrêté
ce que vous l'avez demandé de dire alors
je lui ai demandé de te jeter du haut
d'un point